hier wird heute abend ein hochamt
zelebriert im restaurant alpenrose in
zürich
der ehrengast soll bald eintreffen sein
besuch war lange ungewiss
nun stehen seine leibspeisen auf dem
programm von köchen teenager co
gerade angekommen fergus henderson
spitzenkoch aus los titel von der
schnauze bis zum schwätzchen heißt seine
philosophie möglichst viel soll von
einem schlachttier verwertet werden
unabhängig von henderson kocht auch
teenager cobo seit 20 jahren nach diesem
prinzip
und nun treffen sich die zwei
geistesverwandten in der küche wir
kochen dass da nur mit thymian und einer
guten flasche wein dann kommen zwiebeln
dazu ich fühle mich geehrt
henderson steht seit kurzem wegen seiner
parkinson erkrankung nicht mehr selber
hinter den töpfen aber von seinem
londoner restaurant st john's aus ging
die bewegung aus total und die ganze
welt
es ist einfach höflich ein tier das wir
uns getötet wurde ganz auf zu essen
nicht nur aus gründen der verwertung
sondern auch des geschmacks es gibt
konsistenzen und erhoben die ein filet
nicht bieten kann wie zb kutteln unseren
marken von innen her liebkosen
das ist ein genuss und schließlich macht
es sinn zu zu essen
henderson revolutionierte die britische
küche dem er sich auf vergangenes besand
auf ein erbe das auch teenager cobo in
die wiege gelegt wurde
unsere wahl zur familie und die kamera
so kocht servieren unterbreitet jetzt
kommen manchmal völlig anderes
überall aber eigentlich ist es meine
mutter ist das lang asche kutteln mit
zwiebeln geschmort in milch mit
kartoffelstock das ist ein sehr seitigen
das gericht dass ich aus meiner kindheit
kennen mein vater war ein großer esser
bei meinen eltern genoss ich also eine
gute erziehung wenige menschen wissen
hierzulande noch wie innereien schmecken
noch wenige wie man sie pfiffig
zubereitet ein ganzes spanferkel kommt
sowieso komme auf den tisch
doch heute bei einem schwein weniger als
die hälfte des fleisches überhaupt
verkauft
versteckt handarbeit und liebe dieser
küche
geduld braucht es auch wenn das
spanferkel muss viele stunden schmoren
diese küche beruht auf gesundem
menschenverstand
denn sie verwendet saisonale und lokale
produkte
man muss gar nicht das ganze jahr
hindurch alles essen können also genieße
es einfach zu essen was die natur grad
anbietet überlasse es der natur die
speisekarte zu schreiben nicht
irgendwelchen trends posthotel sagt
henderson zeigt ein kurzlebiger trend
sondern eine haltung eine nachhaltige
antwort auf die auswüchse des exzessiven
luxus fleischkonsums und es scheint dass
er damit weit herum auf gehör stößt das
spezial loste termingeschäfte alpenrose
ein volles haus
ich bin zuversichtlich dass ich sitze
wurden damit auf sie und wurde stimmt
jetzt wird mir die gurte mich weiterhin
bald ein perfekter auftritt für das
viertel perfekt
vor schwänzchen bis zur schnauze